[Musique]
décryptage avec vous elena volochine
bonjour lna bonjour marie paule ce
complexe industriel dassault bst halle
où sont retranchés les combattants du
cognin et avec des civils on l'a
entendue dans le sujet alexandre est
aquarine iep qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
de la stratégie de la russie s'agissant
de ce site s'agissant de cette ville
elle a l'air quand même cette stratégie
assez changeante oui on se souvient du
21 avril dernier lorsque vladimir
poutine avait ordonné à son ministre de
la défense sergueï choïgou assis en face
de lui de cesser l'assaut sur asos
talent mais de bloquer le site de façon
à ce qu'une mouche ne puisse pas volé en
clair de l'assiégé de l'encercler et
d'asphyxié tous ceux qui étaient à
l'intérieur et à ce moment là et bien là
russie démentait le fait que des civils
étaient présents dans ces catacombes
danser bon coeur avec les combats les
combattants du bataillon azoff malgré
ces vidéos qu'on a vu d'ailleurs dans ce
reportage qui circulaient depuis un mois
et demi déjà montrant des femmes des
enfants des personnes âgées des malades
dans ces souterrains mais j'ai retrouvé
un communiqué du ministère russe de la
défense daté de la veille de cette
déclaration de poutine qui disait les
forces armées de la fédération de russie
poursuivant des objectifs purement
humanitaire pour faire un corridor pour
l'évacuation de la population civile qui
se trouvent soit disant selon les
affirmations de kiev sur le territoire
de lusine et ce soi-disant est
importante puisque la russie par là et
bien mettait en doute le fait que ces
civils étaient bien présents c'est une
rhétorique qu'on a retrouvé tout au long
jusqu'à très récemment où finalement et
il devenait clairement impossible de
démentir le fait que ces civils étaient
là alors la russie a changé de
rhétorique disons que cette fois elle
ouvrait bien des corridors humanitaires
mais c'étaient les combattants du
bataillon azoff qui les nazis les
terroristes selon la rhétorique russe
qui retenait en otage ces civils s'en
servaient comme boucliers humains
jusqu'à hier au premier jour d'une trêve
de trois jours annoncés par le ministère
russe de la défense est bien l'armé
craignent en disant que la russie
continue de pilonner ce site impossible
d'évacuer les civils mais la russie dit
non nous on a respecté la trêve mais ce
sont les ukrainiens qui les retient en
otage et qui les empêchent de sortir
elena volochine nous sommes au 72e jour
de cette guerre en ukraine comment
est-ce que ce site d'asos talent a pu
devenir l'un des noeuds de cette guerre
alors marioupol c'était un objectif
stratégique on l'a vu dès le départ de
cette offensive russe a une un trophée
de guerre très important devant passer
dans cette zone d'occupation russes du
dombass de cette république populaire
autoproclamé de donetsk un espace
marioupol est une ville importante
stratégie qu'on l'a dit à de nombreuses
reprises et donc l'armée russe a
encerclé cette ville-là pilonnée pendant
des semaines et il y avait des
évacuations tant bien que mal de civils
mais de nombreux civils d'abord lors de
ce genre de situation refuse de partir
de quitter leur maison jusqu'à la
dernière minute se retrouve coincé et
puis il y en a d'autres qui pour x
raisons ne peuvent pas s'évacuer or
cette usine c'est la plus grande à siri
d'europe onze kilomètres carrés avec des
souterrains de bunkers hérité encore de
l'époque de la guerre froide il ya de
très nombreuses de très nombreux sites
dans cette danse est dans ces régions
d'ex union soviétique qui portent des
banques heures hérité de cette époque et
bien forcément ces populations avec les
combattants ont repoussé retranchés ont
acculé ont fini par faire se retrancher
dans ces souterrains qui sont finalement
devenu une prison parce que pendant deux
mois et bien ils se sont retrouvés
quasiment sans nourriture sans
approvisionnement sans médicaments dans
des souterrains dans des décombres
bombardé jour et nuit et avec dans la
terreur la plus absolue merci beaucoup
elena volochine voix